[Music]
we talk about trash tuesday it's podcast
sometimes we've been known to talk about
occasionally um and we talked about
marsh brought this up by the way i'm
putting this on him um marsh brought
this up
that uh what was my fault i forgot
marcia what was your name
esther i wanted this i want i want to
say blah blah
blah prowitzky
prowisky
prosciutto appreciation
prosciutto prosciutto
um well
i guess she saw the
i guess you saw the video of um
was that a clip
huh
did they clip that i clipped it oh that
was me that's probably why
wait it clipped what oh
school phenomenal i mean we didn't clip
it because we were goofing on her we
were talking about what i'm saying is it
wasn't a clip right yeah it was in a
clip yeah yeah i mean the focus of the
clip wasn't her but i guess
it seems like she was looking up people
talking about trash tuesday and i guess
i titled the trash tuesday anyway
[Laughter]
i love that you guys had like high
school it's so fun i was it was recently
brought to my attention because it's
only building what's going on out there
about us it's only growing um someone
sent me a link to a clip there's like
these two guys that like make fun of
stuff
uh-oh
i mean
guys that's us we're two guys who make
fun of stuff oh that's the kindest way
anybody has ever described you too i was
just gonna say that it is i've never
seen somebody be that nice to us so i
don't like it
don't like it i'm uncomfortable
and they refer to me casually as the
girl that does nothing
mursh refer excuse me
honey honey it's my partner over here
that was me he referred to you as a girl
who does nothing
i'm more interested in your co-host who
jerks off dogs
that's true that's true hey you know
what esther at least you don't jerk off
dogs that we know
of hey at least you don't brag about
jerking off dogs you know why no she
doesn't jerk off dogs because that would
be doing something
anyway birdman casual i don't think she
jerks off dogs because white girls jerk
off dogs and she's clearly jewish
see what i did there yeah i could see
what you'd do
[Music]
can you please not make it
i love making rice uncomfortable do not
compow and sing me please thank you very
much
uh
let's see this is the here this is
i love that you guys had like high
school it's so fun i was it was recently
brought to my attention because it's
only building what's going on out there
about us it's only growing um someone
sent me a link to a clip there's like
these two guys that like make fun of
stuff
and they refer to me casually as the
girl that does nothing
i was like dave dave come in here you
have to hear what they're calling me the
girl who does nothing and he's like why
are you happy about that because finally
people get your brand i know i was like
this is so cute i love it
you're welcome
i feel she was
i can i give some crap i have to give
credit where credit is due she took she
there's a lot of people we've goofed on
and she took it way better
she possesses every characteristic
of a person
that would have taken it badly and
and didn't take it badly so i gotta hear
you know what i mean
like she almost it's like she took it
like a comedian should [ __ ] white
chick from la who does la podcasting i
was like this is gonna i did yesterday
somebody goes oh yeah she mentioned it
and i'm like all right so then royce
pulls the clip up after the show off the
air yesterday and i go all right we've
been through this before
what's it going to be are we going to be
uh in cells are we going to be all right
racist races are we going to be right
like where where uh misogynists
are where are we gonna what's she gonna
say and then we played the clip and i'm
like
oh
damn
that's like one of two people in la that
knows how to actually [ __ ] take a
joke so i would do like to give credit
for that
um
did you want us to do like games or
something i just thought there would be
some sort of structure so then i also
realized that during that whole thing
anthony just like had to be sitting
there
and i don't know why i don't know why
that made me what maybe giggle by the
way somebody else who he famously made
fun of
oh yeah by the way he shits on norm in
this episode too wait norm mcdonald yeah
talking about how mean he always was and
oh wait whoa
no i would where's hold on
somewhere in the episode hold on oh oh
it's auto filling it's auto filling
uh
let's see here
[Music]
oh man apparently he's talked [ __ ] about
norm a few times oh yeah he does not
like norman mcdonald what
okay how can i know how to find i know
hold on i know how to find the clip too
just this stupid transcript somebody
taught me a a trick
[Music]
okay here it
is i'm not happy with you and i'm like
i'm not happy with him i don't know
what's going on here it was so he was so
he's a little bit like but in a weird
way and she was like talking about how
she wanted to beat the [ __ ] out of me
back at norm here we go
he was nasty with a lot of people okay i
mean do you like norman i would fight
oh fight on camera really and after
every episode we would meet up and that
was what on last comic standing right or
something like that one of those
comments yeah that's comic standing okay
and he'd be like well he's it's going to
be great television because it was like
they're like you guys need to talk this
out because he would be so mean and the
audience was like what so i would come
and come back at norm try to get the
audience back and then he was getting
mad about me coming back at him
i doubt he was i i'm sorry but there's
not going to be a universe where i will
be taking anthony jeselyn excited
against nor macdonald
none of the judges were used to thought
remember he's the one that retweeted the
[ __ ] how everyone in gas digital was
[ __ ] racist articles that person
wrote remember that
post was going to be mean to them yeah
and so i was like i'm on the comic side
yeah i'm going to be mean to you and it
was just it was so uncomfortable the
whole thing well that was so you were
simping for comics that's what that was
why i felt so tricked because the
producers were like hey we're doing this
differently it's not like simon cowell
vibes like it's going everyone's a comic
here we're going to be really it's all
positive constructive so everyone was
going ew now i look now would lost me
again yeah
right there positive it's a f
i know i know
still a woman
and then like we're not expecting a
fight and then when norm would like
suddenly say rude [ __ ]
suddenly say
rude [ __ ] you mean again and i
i'm
be a comic
and by the way anthony jeselnik is one
to talk anthony just so i can say some
of the horrific jokes i've ever heard in
my life
yeah but that's on stage dude that's
different oh okay he respects the crap
he's playing a character he respects the
craft yeah it's different when you're
playing a character i hate that people
like this man
i
reacted honestly in the moment i was
like
i'm not taking this so yeah that is my
memory you guys fought a lot yeah did he
lose that fight too
um
you guys fought a lot did he lose that
fight too
so is she referring because he allowed
us he lost his fight to cancer
i guess
no i'm just wondering i mean not that i
care i'm not offended that seems mean
i'm not offended by it or anything it
seems me but it just doesn't seem like
something on brand you know
there you go
it's not on brand for a [ __ ] wes
anderson set
well i i took the job because i wanted
to work with norm so they were like no
one's not happy with you and i'm like
i'm not happy with him i don't know
what's going on here it was so he was so
he's a little bit like but in a weird
way wasn't he always like you couldn't
tell if he was doing a bit or not that's
how i always felt yeah it's called being
a really good comic
that's called being so [ __ ] good that
you can't these [ __ ] people are weak
man oh when i i mean the [ __ ] didn't
make sense it wasn't a bit it was like
he was pontificating about things and
female comics especially got it got it
right
and and it didn't make it he would love
someone and hate someone else and didn't
make that there was no rhyme or reason
sarah silverman's great who's funnier
than sarah
silverman except a bunch of dudes except
a bunch of dudes
one of my favorite nor macdonald jokes
except a bunch of dudes
that it was just awkward and weird and
he would go on for a long time yeah but
i felt like i had to kind of not roast
him but i had to kind of take control of
the show otherwise it was like the norm
the norm hour and i think roseanne and
keenan were like what's he doing yeah
what's norm talking about the norm hour
oh she mean the guy who's the funniest
one who's i don't know the most famous
one out of all of you yeah yeah it was
real weird when roseanne's going is this
guy crazy
oh because roseanne's crazy
um you'd sit on a wes anderson set next
to two [ __ ] pink flamingos but you're
probably some sort of podcasting slave
warehouse where they have a bunch of
different sets the only difference
between you and one of those webcam
warehouses that you don't have to
[ __ ] show your [ __ ] yet
i picture all these little podcast
studios or in all these like those boxes
like in the end of raiders of the lost
ark yes exactly exactly
i remember he said something like it's
calling me like the biggest
disappointment of his night and i was
like
rip norm
king [ __ ]
that's so daddy
why are you like i can't disappoint you
that's so daddy these people i i can't i
i don't want to be in this world anymore
royce i don't know how people talk i
hate everything yeah i hate everyone no
i think i said something like you're my
dad's favorite comic or like i don't
know it was just so awkward it was so
weird and then afterwards i was freaking
out
oh i had to comfort like there were
people crying afterwards and i'd like
don't let them see you cry like [ __ ]
last comic standing like i'm the best
comic in three a three mile radius and i
wouldn't make it three minutes on this
show like
okay a lot of one pack here a lot of
unpack here number one
ew captain save a hoe
are you sitting there
i had to come swooping in he's sleeping
i had to comfort all these calm i had to
comfort them only anthony justlneck can
save the day
and then on top of that to say you're
the best comic in a three mile radius
when you are on a show with norm [ __ ]
mcdonald
is the most arrogant thing i've ever
seen a comic say
yeah well jessalnik's always been he's
always uh thought who the [ __ ] he was
i'm the funniest comic and i wouldn't
make it five minutes on the bed but what
a [ __ ] [ __ ] what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
seriously
like why was anyone upset
i i was just i hated the process i know
you are nice to comics yeah but for the
most part yeah there was one girl i
remember this girl got introduced this
is great like i introduced everyone but
there's one they're like her dad's here
they were like an indian family and the
dad came out with a heavy accent was
like i'm so proud of my daughter and she
walks out like a really nice dress does
three minutes and then norm says
i go norm what do you think norm goes
what the hell is going on here i was
told i'd be here to judge the hundred
funniest people in the country i don't
think you're one of the hundred funniest
people in this room
which is
brutal
it's funny it's pretty funny
and i
i lost it so hard why are you okay so it
was funny why are you laughing i thought
it was the funniest thing i've ever
but okay pick a [ __ ] lane right
what's what's going on is he bipolar
like on the one hand
so mean and uh
funny to be mean to someone in front of
their parents
it's actually nice it's like what is it
he could be funny it was funny great but
there were a lot of times he wasn't
being funny yeah that is such a glimpse
into these people man
it's like they just
he just did a whole [ __ ] soliloquy
about how
norm was mean and mean for no reason and
you know there's ways you could be funny
without just being mean
and then it ends with him
like glowingly recalling the time he was
mean and then annie lederman going
yeah being mean to people for their
parents is funny i i yeah i don't
understand what's going on what's going
on right but honestly anthony jeselnik
fits with these people he's sitting
around with a bunch of other broads
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] clickety [ __ ]
[ __ ] clucking about how mean norm
mcdonald was when he was around
even though these people couldn't
couldn't [ __ ]
one day
in one day couldn't do in one day
couldn't fill his shoes at anything in
[ __ ] anything nor mcdonald tweeting
about golf is funnier than anything any
of these people have ever done
they'll fix this he could be funny and
if it was funny great he if it was funny
great so now we go into the territory of
whether or not you think somebody
anthony justin like is the person
because he's the merch i don't know if
you know this the funniest comic in a
three mile radius well i call i i've for
years people know i've called anthony
justin the arbiter
what an idiot right what an idiot yeah
man but there were a lot of people even
have a degree from the san francisco
comedy college i bet yeah you know mark
harley yeah you know not my sir i know
mark harley i make fun of mark harley
and you sir are no mark harley
it wasn't being funny it was just like
why are you being so mean because it's
funny because it is funny
did this like hack comic you can just
you call you just called the comic a
hack
you you
you you just
why are you being so mean because
this whole mentality is not based on
being a genuinely good altruistic person
i just don't get this la la mentality is
be nice
not be real not be truthful not be
helpful be nice so being nice for the
sake of being nice not actually
which means we could talk [ __ ] about
this hack comedian when we're hanging
out later being all too faced
we can't do it right here because that's
mean very good point that's actually a
really good point because
comics always talk [ __ ] all the time and
i respect the ones that do it when
you're sitting there i prefer that yeah
dismiss and be like yeah not my thing
you know he always said he didn't like
crazy female comedians right didn't he
say he didn't think women in front of
you know that was a you know that was a
bit right
you
you know that he said one of his
favorite comedians of all time was
roseanne right like you know that are
you aware of that like these people
these old wives because norm had joked
about women not being funny right
he didn't actually think women weren't
funny
it's so [ __ ] annoying
yeah he had some uh he had some opinions
though like what
how are we doing this yes it's banana
break time are you
are you a banana fan oh you get get
ready royce's got bryce is gonna lose
his wine what are they doing
right rice what are they doing this
segment has production what are they
doing what are they doing all right what
are they doing
what is this virgie
i mean sure like i'm a fan
what
i thought i was having a stroke this is
a segment of them eating bananas
well what do you think it is
norm was right women are not funny
it's a banana break royce they just went
they just went from saying it's so hold
on i just want to put something out can
i contrast something please for i need
to do this or it's going to kill me they
just went from
it's so annoying when people think that
female comics aren't funny that was the
line that's what she just said it's so
annoying and they go from that
immediately without a second too
[Music]
same breath
huh now that's funny dude oh it is funny
no no royce think about it right she
goes i can't believe people always say
women aren't funny and then she
immediately does something unfunny that
is pretty brilliant
somebody said please for the love of god
turn off the heart on collider
[Laughter]
i'm saying
these people are [ __ ] the worst and
by the way this all started with oh she
took a joke and now i'm i'm again
already i'm already again going like
what is this a banana break
do you not want a nice delicious banana
why don't we you have a drug break like
an adult okay [ __ ] crazy probably
have low potassium
okay i'm done listening to these four
women talk about why norm was so mean to
them
you